bon on fait à nous deux raconte moi toi
quand tu as c'était une gamine tu étais
déjà amoureuse du son de la guitare je
suis supplier tes parents pour qui
t'offre une guitare électrique c'est
vrai vous avez complètement à sept ans
j'étais voir ma mère et je les écoute
j'aimerais énormément avoir une guitare
électrique
elle m'a dit écoute c'est pas que le pam
est un petit peu jaune quand même un peu
elle a cédé quelques années après quand
même mais mais elle a cédé et alors
aujourd'hui ça fait quoi a joué avec une
sorte de guitar hero avec carole quand
les énormes une méchante pour moi c est
impressionnant c'est un énorme cadeau
des gens mais ça c'est la magie
renversante hisser au fait vous êtes une
équipe remercient véritable sa mère si
on prend tous les compléments alors
d'elle comme commis un vol d'oies tu as
commencé la guitare en autodidacte et
puis après tu as fait des études de
guitare tu t'es exilés outre-manche
vente a appris les deux le tarn dans une
école de musique en angleterre et puis
tard suis ton diplôme des mains une des
plus grandes figures du rock anglais
raconte ça je voulais vraiment me
professionnaliser dans la musique donc
j'ai fait un cursus universitaire de
quatre ans et à la fin du jeu cursus
universitaire j'ai reçu mon diplôme de
la part de roger daltrey le chanteur des
who
donc ce n'est pas rien quand on
rencontre et qu'on salue une telle une
telle personne mais ce que ça veut dire
que l'europe est dans ton adn j'ai
toujours été bercé par des totaux
supertramp ac dc
par ton papa notamment de la part d'un
pas pareil pour moi ça n'a jamais
vraiment quitté
j'ai choisi un autre mot style toujours
pas très très long alors ton c'est
justement dans la presse on te
catégorise comme artiste reggae
ça te plaît pas forcément lors comment
tu définirais quoi sans style ça ne me
dérange pas mais c'est pas vraiment que
reggae reggae si je dois me définir tu
mets un peu de rock un petit peu de dope
un petit peu d'oscar un petit peu de
chansons et la magie robert de voir sur
scène tout à l'heure mais un merci aux
régatiers dit en tout cas
[Musique]